If you want to know where you are,
you can check on your phone.
It listens for signals from whole
constellations of satellites in orbit,
and by triangulating all those signals
and using a lot of maths,
it works out where you are
and shows you a little dot on a map.
But how do the satellites
know where they are?
There aren't any landmarks in orbit
for them to refer to.
If satellites are in a high enough orbit,
well away from the atmosphere,
then they can predict their position.
They'll just keep orbiting in
about the same path:
there’s no atmosphere to slow them down.
But that's not precise enough.
There will be distortions
caused by gravity from the sun and moon,
or even from mountain ranges
down on Earth.
So maybe they could use the other
satellite signals, like GPS.
But if they're all relying on each other,
that could steadily drift apart from reality.
Maybe they could track the stars
or the features down on Earth,
but that's not precise enough either.
At some point, something down here on
Earth has to look up in the sky
and work out the position precisely.
And one of those somethings is hidden away
in the countryside of southern England.
It looks like a regular observatory,
but it's not looking at the stars.
- We track manmade satellites
in various orbits doing various jobs.
They all have to have special reflectors
that enables the light
to be returned to us.
And so we can measure the time of flight,
and from the time of flight, derive the distance.
You send out a very short
pulse of laser light.
You do that a thousand times a second.
Each of those shots, because you're using
such a tiny short-pulsed laser,
is 10 picoseconds long,
which is about 3mm.
That's the limitation on your precision.
So each shot is about 3-4mm precision.
- This station works around the clock,
whenever the sky is clear.
That's why I'm here today:
there will be some genuine observations
when the clouds break, but right now,
I'm not actually disrupting anything.
But it does look
significantly better after dark.
- Because it's a laser, it's
a very specific wavelength.
So you can filter, and that's
what lets you work in day and night.
The main problem with the atmosphere is:
the speed of light in a vacuum
is a very well known constant.
The speed of light
through the atmosphere is variable
according to the mainly the pressure,
but also temperature and humidity.
So we measure those things
on site, as well.
There's probably about 35 active stations
scattered around the globe,
located predominantly
in the northern hemisphere,
which is a slight problem
from a science point of view.
You'd like them evenly distributed
all around the globe.
There's a couple in Australia
which are really important
because they're providing a bulk
of the data from southern hemisphere.
Ideally, we'd have a more
even distribution.
- Of course, as the light fades,
there's one assumption
that we've been working on
throughout this video:
that the earth, the ground
we're standing on, doesn't move.
And that's not strictly true.
- In the early days of laser
ranging, in the 60s,
it was the primary method
by which they were deriving
those early measurements of the drift
between us and North America.
So you can see long-term trends,
like the ice caps
melting and the redistribution of mass
from the ice caps to the equator.
All the data goes off
to international databases,
from all the sites all around the world.
Anyone, any researcher, anywhere
can go and grab the international data set,
the data from us,
from Australia, from North America,
from China, from Russia,
and can use that data to derive the orbits
and do the research they need to do.
- Thanks very much to all the team
at the Space Geodesy Facility.
You can find out more about them and
their work at the link in the description.